siri vous de bonsoir
alors avec vous on change pas de sujet
on va rester dans la drogue drogue a
accepté par la société puisque c'est
celle que prennent les coureurs
cyclistes
alors vous êtes la femme de villy route
soigneur de l'équipe festina arrêté en
1998 ce qui a déclenché la plus grosse
affaire de l'histoire et on l'avait
reçue ici votre votre mari willy pour
son deuxième livre qui s'appelait sexe
mensonges et petit vélo maladie
tout est dit récemment à l'occasion de
la sphère cofidis des femmes de deux
coureurs ou des femmes de soigneur en
tous les cas des femmes de doper ont
pris la parole pour raconter leur vie
brisée et dénoncer la loi du milieu il
ya ellis gaumont il ya alors atteinte
aux ti et vous sylvie vote alors vous
dites six ans après festina
rien n'a changé en fait ou plutôt si
maintenance et des transfusions
sanguines des produits vétérinaires mais
en fait c'est toujours la même chose
qu'à l'époque de l'affairé festina
mais en résumé on va dire ça n'a pas
servi de leçon en gros ça sert
strictement à rien le problème il est là
et ce qui se passe c'est que chez fait
chez festina par la force des choses il
avait essayé de
d'un petit peu contrôlées par des
médecins par le directeur sportif
histoire d'éviter de faire n'importe
quoi ce qui veut pas dire que c'était
bien je ne dis pas ça mais qu'est ce
qu'on se retrouve s'il en a pris puisque
qu est-ce qu on se retrouve avec des
transfusions de des autotransfusions des
produits vétérinaires dans des camions
dans des camping-cars qui suivent la
caravane de toutes les courses sans
suivi médical
s'ensuivit bouddhique sarkozy veut
mettre des flics dans les écoles
pourquoi n'auraient pas des flics qu'il
fallait contrôle antidopage je dis que
simplement et sarkozy mais des flics
dans les écoles ça et me sèye même petit
peu la population et c'est normal parce
que je trouve c'est complètement nul
mais bon fermons la parenthèse
quand les flics ont fait des descentes
ou sur le tour de france ou sur le tour
d'italie ça fait un drame il ya eu quand
même grève des coureurs tout le monde
s'est arrêté parce que c'est dramatique
enfin je veux dire de toute façon ils
vivent dans une sphère est dans un
milieu qui est à part donc ils sont dans
leur monde
il s'auto contrôler c'est comme si vous
aviez un directeur de société qui a la
foi qui à la fois senica liste voilà cc
je veux dire c'est comme les hommes
politiques et surtout en gros en gros tu
en voilà comment il va où il ya besoin
je la verrais bien vous envoie le bon
jour fait là bas j'avais déjà tu te
souviens nous les voûtes c'est
l'inventeur du beau belle c'est pas les
mêmes termes un cépage à gérer n'empêche
certains brevets soient déposées quelque
part à un procès mais les impôts après
avec les on n'a pas dormi pendant trois
semaines ils auront plus de drogue là
non je suis en arrêt téléthon trop tard
mon avis qu'est ce qu'il fait là de quoi
y vit sérieusement là il travaille dans
une société transports ouais voilà
et vous vous trouvez toujours en
fonction publique jours thierry vous
êtes oublier des impôts n'ont pas osé
dommage
pourquoi je travaille dans une
collectivité territoriale
cette voie là alors justement quand vous
avez rencontré ou eleven en 1983 bon
vous travaillez déjà dans la fonction
publique à l'époque 8 des pharmaciens
liquide des soigneurs et alors le soir
comme ça à l'époque j'étais assez cool
vous dites vous en parliez sur un coin
de table parler du dopage comme vous
auriez parler d'autre chose s'il avait
été maçon ou boulanger est quoi ce
tellement j'étais assez normal mais ça
prenait pas des proportions fait
doucement avec les maçons non mais c'est
vrai nous à l'époque c'était pas un
drame c'était pas du tout un drame et
que ça reste est vraiment dans des dans
des proportions veut dire fait normal
job déraisonnable déjà mais non mais
c'était pas un souci parce que ça reste
et ça reste et ça va bouffer pahlavi
comme l'a bouffé après quoi vous avez
déjà quand même le p ô les hormones de
croissance naturelle et non corticaux
anabolisants donc à la fin des années 80
les pratiques étaient assez limitées
discrète raisonnable ouais ensuite fin
80 début 90 c'est arrivé avec le
cyclisme italien avait des coureurs
italiens lteo voilà les italiens qui ont
mené le pays et de l'avant c'est vrai
que ça a complètement dégénéré et le
tournant ça a été en 95 96
là ça commençait à devenir à venir très
chaud parce que c'était plus des soins
des préparations mais c'est carrément de
la drogue ce qui se passe vous parlez
vous parlez comme le milieu thierry
attention avant soit une préparation
soit une préparation c'est le mot qui ne
parlait pas de dopage voilà on parlait
pas je ne parlais pas de dopage de
l'accès de l'extérieur on parlait de la
page
et là ça commence à être très chaud dont
95 96 7 les mecs sont devenus accros
à leur truc c'est arrivé c'est vrai avec
toute une génération de coureurs
italiens hollandais
d'ailleurs il ya eu des décès ça a été
quand même dramatique
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi appris bon de
je suppose que bruno roussel à essayer
d'encadrer ça
c'était c'était à la limite beaucoup
plus intelligente que de laisser faire
la distribution de potion magique mais
embellie qui n'ont pas cette fois ci le
peuvent être ceux des amphétamines la
caféine de l'héroïne de la cocaïne quoi
c'est pas ça avant de faire les courses
parce que ça c'était détectable contrôle
antidopage
ils prenaient ça à l'entraînement et
après il y avait le côté complètement
festif vous preniez ça en soirée pour
tina oui c'est bien ce qui est
incroyable c'est qu'en fait ils
prenaient du pot belge pour pour
l'entraînement mais ils on prenait aussi
pour faire des soirées ils ont prôné
pour faire les frais aller sur un site
qu'ils étaient drogués en fait voilà
mais moi ils achètent donc les tenants
c'était cet entraînement c'était ça mais
un extérieur de l'extérieur on disait ça
mais non c'était quelque chose qui était
conseil sait vraiment qui bannit c'est
dans leur langage le dopage et le dopage
la dope et la drogue ce qui est des
moteurs de ce soir à sion soit plus au
ramadan d'accord c'est le poids qu'il
chantait ma préparation
une fois qu'ils entraînent pour faire du
fait et vous vous alliez à des fêtes de
coire cyclistes et puis vous étiez un
peu largué vous amusez pas comme les
autres vous avez essayé d'en prendre
oui deux fois piqûre dans l'épaule ouais
et alors ça vous a fait quoi
elle a fait deuxième il est resté
éveillé toute la nuit
ouais jusqu'à 10h à wemmel à total
s'appuie sur la route avec nous à
l'époque alors le comble c'est après
c'est la période 95 98 alors là ça
commence sérieusement à bouffer votre
vie de famille vous dites dans le bac à
légumes du frigo plus de produits
dopants que d'autre chose on voulait
plus rien mettre cet habitant un proto
feu de broussailles et place afin que je
vous dis je dise le frigo était à moitié
mon mari c'est ce qu'ils voulaient c'est
quoi le budget ricaine dans une équipe
les buts g km
il faut demander au courant parce que
c'est eux qui paient ça avec leurs
primes est ce qu'ils gagnaient au noir
central et du recteur de coincer de
directeur dès maintenant il sentait pas
bien parce que je veux dire c'est ils
ont obligé personne
moi j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un qu'on a
jamais vu
alors là donc vous vous refusez
finalement que les gens viennent se
servir chez vous un vous voulez pas ce
qui fait que votre mari will il est
obligé de remplir son coffre et de faire
le tour d'europe pour suivre les cours
et pour les contester son métier j'étais
son métier glaciaire aussi ce qui
faisait où il est vous deux pour tenir
la contenir le coût bas ils en prenaient
aussi comme les autres c'est à dire que
ça veut dire que le soigneur en prenait
d'atteindre les soigneurs empoignant m
année la fin du soutien elle a pris deux
fois l'accord sera bon et les wallabies
principalement eu quand même
et à ce moment là vous dites ça devient
complètement obsessionnelle les piqûres
avant la course
vous dites j'entendais plus parler de
sport quoi c'était ça on n'entendait
plus parler de sport on entendu parler
de soi une préparation normale de
croissance de p&o de contrôle de voila
on n'entendait plus du tout parler de
sport c'était devenu secondaire
d'ailleurs si vous regardez une caravane
youtube
une caravane du tour de france vous avez
à peu près 5000 ses mille personnes pour
200 coureurs
quels sont les termes maintenant et
c'est là en 1998 dont 4 affaire festina
bruno roussel le patron de l'équipe
festina vous appelle il vous dit brûle
les carnets dis à ton mari qui prennent
tout sur lui on va tout payer
on va leur ouvrir on va s'arranger comme
ça parce que moi j'ai appris mon mari
est en prison par un coup de téléphone
de la police judiciaire en me disant à
votre mari il va bien je vais vous
passez deux minutes vous posez aucune
question
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
lendemain en fait ce qui vous a énervé
c'est que dont on vous demande vous dit
voilà il va tout prendre mais c'est pas
grave on va payer
et le lendemain vous voyez le départ de
l'étape et là ils sont tous contents
comme si de rien n'était de rien n'était
je commence par entendre une roue celle
qui dit je comprends pas qu est ce qui
se passe parce que mon équipe est au
complet et il me manque personne et
dans les coureurs entre autres à
l'époque qui disent je connais à peine
j'ai pas qu'est ce que c'est si tragique
pour les autres jouent pas au courant je
me suis pas ici parce que j'ai dit mais
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui me raconte
pas ce que moi je n'ai vu autant de
douilles et avec sa perf
je veux dire dans les chambres d'hôtel
c'était ça m'énerve donc à vous décidez
vous dit
chacun joue dans son camp crettenand moi
je suis moi aussi eu et voilà on va pas
tout prendre sans rien dire non j'ai dit
moi j'ai rappelé bruno roussel en
irlande et j'ai dit c'est bon je compris
tout de suite il fallait pas jouer ce
jeu parce qu'il était mort donc au lieu
de brûler les carnets voulait cacher je
lisais cachez vous savez ou chez une
amie paysanne voilà dans les tables des
vaches
voilà alors pas non on écoute maintenant
tout le temps que tout le monde le juge
tout le monde perd parce que moi j'ai eu
droit la perquisition la maison ou si le
père noël était vide et le frigo était
vide parce que quand il est parti pour
le tour j'ai dit je veux strictement
plus rien la maison du pont toute ta
mère des tul hager sens parce que les
voûtes certains c'était comme ça et
malgré ça vous avez gardé de l'amour
pour willy lagarde et de l'amour pour
vous malgré ça votre pays n'a pas son
fiancé riels faut lui demander ça ouais
bah vous voyez bien quand même
ouais ça va toujours ça va voilà enfin
en tous les cas à l'instruction vous
produirez ses fameux carnets que vous
aviez sauver de sauver du feu n'allez
pas vous êtes menacé vous recevez
beaucoup de coups de fil anonymes le
soir en arrivant anonyme de kim je me
rappelle pas ça c'est embêtant c'est des
grands courageux toujours des couilles
qui forment s'agit dit toujours un
voilà en fait votre mari a parlé aux
procès mais ça aurait changé quoi ça
arrive apparemment ça rien changé la
seule chose c'est que maintenant on ne
peut plus dire qu'il se fait ils ne
peuvent plus dire qu'ils savent pas
comment ça se passe qu'est ce qu'ils
risquent je pense que c'est vrai à
l'époque personne savait ce qu'ils
risquaient parce que quand il se faisait
attraper il ya eu x fois où ils se sont
quand même fait attraper ou à une
frontière a fait attraper effet vérifier
alors ils s'en sortaient en donnant une
casquette en cuissard
you quoi j'aurais tout était bon et
dédicacer une photo et ça roulait cette
fois sa part où les sap a roulé ce qui
me scandalise le plus c'est que les
personnes qui parlent sont bannis du
milieu c'est ça si ce qui est arrivé à
vous et à votre mari mais c'est moi
personnellement je m'en fous vous jouez
monde demande cc on est venu demander
mon témoignage je le dis volontiers je
dis la vérité parce que c'est
complètement nul 2-2 rien dire alors
tout le monde dit on veut faire avancer
les choses et personne ne parut faut que
ça soit encore une fois les femmes qui
parlaient de toute façon le problème il
est là au lieu de bon ils sont une
poignée à avoir parlé et au lieu de les
bannir je dire de les mettre
complètement de côté c'est les gros
méchants qui ont fait exploser la bulle
et prend l'expérience des gens qui
savent le problème des contrôles
antidopage c'est qu'ils ont une
génération de coureurs de retard ils ont
dix ans le pays est arrivé fin 80 début
90 premiers contrôles de le paix au 1er
janvier 98 voilà donc 8 en 8 9 10 ans
voilà une génération
donc ça va changer en gros ce qu'ils
sont en train de se mettre dans les
fesses actuellement ce sera ça sortira
dans dix ans quoi ils trouveront les
contrôles dans dix ans qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire rien l'investor maintenant
tout de suite des choses que lui mais
qu'est ce que ben écoutez écoutez les
gens qui savent comment ça fonctionne
qu'on leur dise comment ça fonctionne et
peut-être pourquoi pas un coming out
c'est la mode comme des sportifs ça
commence un petit peu qu'il fasse mais
bon il faut sauver ou les voûtes nom de
son vélo rail va très bien tu penses
quoi tout ça c'est insensé quand même
toi tu te fais c'est vrai tu fais [ __ ]
en taule pour exactement les mêmes trucs
et qui fait mal qu'après les mecs qui
font le tour de france j'ai pas gagné
d'étape mais la preuve que ça sert à
rien de toute façon la preuve c'est que
chez festina
il y avait dopage qui était organisée
depuis trois quatre cinq ans exactement
je sais plus et ils se sentent jamais
fait choper à une contrôle ils se sont
fait jamais ils se sont fait chaud c'est
mon mari qui se fait c'est ce qui s'est
fait choper à la barre est actuellement
les mecs qui sportives qui se font
attraper ses plis scellés plus couillon
du peloton le chez festina
les contrôles inopinés étaient au
courant le jour et l'heure auxquelles
d'avoir lieu dans l'europe inopinés donc
conclusion des courses
le tout c'était de ne pas se faire
choper avec plus de 50% de taux
d'hématocrite dans le sang hop on a vidé
il avait une petite machine par laquelle
il contrôlait le ce1 il y avait 52 53
perfusion dont on faisait descendre le
taux s'était finie très compliqué voilà
pourquoi c'est le disent pas les mecs je
vais me parlez vous savez tous vos jeux
c'est des trucs pas peut-être me flingue
en sortant mais non alors tous les cas
merci d'avoir témoigné merci ciblés et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais 1
pouces bleus